préfère les rôles de neige donc c'est
celui pour qui le monde renaît chaque
matin avec lui même comme si la création
du a créé le monde paraît-il un seul
jour mais pas du tout dur créé le monde
chaque matin et le naïve leur crée en
même temps ça va très loin cette
histoire là parce que la naïveté ainsi
conçu est à la source de toute création
que l'on soit épicier sharks qui est
grand temps de télévision comme vous ou
écrivains architectes ou maçon et puis
on ne peut créer que s'ils renient naïl
chose à me dire pourquoi pourquoi il ya
parce que tous les thèmes créateur de la
vie sont dans les mains de l'enfant
il n'y a pas de thème créateur en dehors
de l'enfance s'y voit la tête de daniel
cohn bendit parle du chef public a
démonté un truc pareil sous coucy croit
le compte s'ils pouvaient pas tenir si
tient le rôle du naïf de jouer le maïs
genou par phare est le titre qui
répètent pendant 10 minutes shun ichi
life celui-là il va croire naïvement ou
série g2 le croit puisque on le met sur
le titre mon goût et non mais je veux
dire on va continuer c'est très très
bien a été repêché matière occupera
sinon je vous dirai tout à noeuds dans
les quatre circonstances où je vous ai
rencontrés au bal alors là dit le toutou
et à ce titre gardent elles n'ont jamais
alors c'est louche
non je veux parler quand vous parlerez
je vous laisse près par la ffb
la jeunesse moment oui la jeunesse me
manque parce que j'écoute l'album il
peut rigoler mais c'est vrai parce que
le j'ai passé une grande partie de ma
vie dans l'enseignement
j'étais dix ans professeur et ensuite eh
oui dénoncé me gênait beaucoup de
joueurs mais j'ai continué mais j'espère
que vous ricanez un nouveau gîte leur
audition dokoui la jeunesse verte oui la
jeunesse vraiment pas ce que j'ai vécu
avec elle j'ai vécu pour elle j'ai
consacré une grande partie de mon oeuvre
elle beaucoup beaucoup de livres c'est à
dire d'abord mon histoire de l'it
d'abord mon niveau 40 enfants et
beaucoup d'eau mais est-ce que la
jeunesse actuelle vente mais encore plus
que jamais